what do you get out of sexting like oh
my god I can't wait to see that photo
get right to it like who are you
touching today we're gonna be reading
scenarios and deciding with it or not
it's chaining of course like any kind of
sexual type stuff is cheating than you
have like the the online slide in the DM
type of situation if you have to
question if it's cheating or not then
it's probably cheating for me your
partner cuddle / spoons with someone
else
cheating or not I would rather have my
husband just someone else cuddle with
when I spoon it's pretty intense so if I
would have spent someone else I would I
would say that I was cheating my wife
was doing it cool if I was doing it
that's not good
of course this is all emotional cheating
which is equivalent to physical I don't
see a difference in a relationship where
you like something that you it's like
hopefully you'd be doing that to your
partner so it's like well why aren't you
sending me the nudes your partner kisses
someone else
cheating or naw let's start with cheap
innocent cheek kiss that cheek nose to
the mouth um to like pay that's fine
still and they actually slips the top so
I'm gonna do this thing yeah where it's
no yeah no yeah if I get cold forth or
other diseases your partner's flirting
with someone through text but never
meets up cheating or nah
oh we swipe your left phone these are
right
tuition like if that's the case then why
does your partner have tender to begin
with it I think it's a problem because
like your partner then is looking for
some kind of validation or some
something through tags and it would make
me incredibly uncomfortable I will just
be being myself and my friends like oh
you were flirting so hard too much was
that I wasn't even aware that I was
flirting so I feel like I could easily
be texting someone and not know that I'm
flirting and be like oh this is just me
talking at the end of the day just talk
with your partner and make sure you're
on the same page about what she is
kidding it's like you just bought you
know a popsicle you want to keep that
ice cream to yourself you physically go
all the way with someone then yeah you
just violated that relationship outside
of that dome I mean if you look at
somebody and they flirt a little bit you
got them just stay true to home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]